Mm-hmm. All right.
Hey, palsies.
My name is Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help so much,
I'm making these
videos called...
If you know me, you know I love
high-fives and handshakes.
I even have a song about 'em.
♪ High fives and handshakes ♪
♪ Mm, mm ♪
♪ What a difference a plan makes ♪
But what if you're not close enough
to give somebody
a high-five or a handshake?
Or-- Or-or-or what if somebody
doesn't like 'em as much as you do,
and they say,
"No, thank you, please"?
What do you do then?
Well, good news! I thought of
two new things you can do
instead of
high fives and handshakes.
Yeah, these things are so great
because you can do 'em
if someone is far away
or if you're talking to someone on video,
or you can even do 'em to yourself
in the mirror.
But I'm not gonna tell you what
these two things are.
I'm gonna sing about 'em instead.
Music, please!
♪ Bright smiles and hand waves ♪
♪ Shining out like the sun's rays ♪
♪ 'Cause the sun may be distant,
but it's still warm and bright ♪
♪ With a smile, you can share
with everybody in sight ♪
All right!
♪ No matter how far,
the brighter you glow ♪
♪ The better for reaching
everybody you know ♪
♪ Shining out like the sun's rays ♪
♪ Bright smiles and hand waves ♪
Whoo!
♪ Bright smiles and hand waves, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Bright smiles and hand waves ♪
Thanks for watching,
and I'll be back soon.
Until then, make sure to help
the people and monsters around you.
Because everyone
loves a helping hand.
Bright smiles and hand waves, everybody!